one year after the fall of afghanistan
millions of afghans remain trapped in
poverty and hunger but many of those who
escaped are starting new lives in
countries like the u.s cbs news tech and
politics reporter his name is moussa
deek badar knows exactly what that feels
like the taliban forced his family out
of afghanistan when they ruled the
country back in the 1990s so we asked
him to reflect on his own experiences as
a refugee and what it means to be
afghan-american
[Music]
the images of afghans chasing after a
u.s military plane and clinging to their
final hope for freedom
reminded me of my family's struggle to
escape the taliban nearly 30 years ago i
was born in the basement of our home in
kabul in 1992
the taliban were just beginning to
conquer afghanistan
rockets and bombs exploded outside while
my family sought shelter underground
during the civil war
my mother an airline attendant and my
father a radio journalist who had been
reporting on the taliban's human rights
abuses became targets once the group
took control of afghanistan in 1996
a grenade meant to kill my father
took the life of my grandfather and
injured other members of our family
we soon found ourselves in the same
situation that millions of afghans are
now in stay home and face potential
death or leave everything behind in
search of freedom and opportunity
we left kabul in the middle of the night
hiding in homes of family and friends
for months before arriving at a refugee
camp in pakistan i was 6 years old when
my brother and i started working 10 hour
days to help put food on the table
we weaved carpets that sold as luxury
items in america and europe my dad's
polio limits his physical mobility so he
homeschooled us at night my mom waited
outside various embassies in islamabad
desperately trying to submit a refugee
visa application
we slept on the floor and shared simple
treats like birthday cakes but continued
to work toward a better future
then in may of 2003 we got a
life-changing call
pack your bags you're going to america
i was 10 years old could barely say
hello or how are you in english but soon
found myself translating government
documents from my parents
we resettled in a small two-bedroom
apartment in concord california
my mom would roll sandwiches at subway
in san francisco during the day and take
english lessons after her shift
i put on my team usa jersey watched
reruns of full house and the fresh
prince of bel air and carried a
basketball around to fit in
for me education was the catalyst to
success in america gave me the
opportunity to seize it the community in
the bay area provided a welcoming
environment and gave me a chance to
proudly call myself afghan american
student volunteers here at the athenian
school tutored me on the weekends took
me to giants games and it was at this
high school while on a full scholarship
where i discovered my passion for
reporting and telling stories
i studied journalism in washington dc a
place i stayed for the next 10 years my
dad often says coming to america was
like winning the lottery but he also
reminds me that prosperity isn't
guaranteed
my family's success is the success of
america and the countless mentors
teachers friends and colleagues who have
supported us at every step we're keeping
an eye on two interesting races here i
followed after my father and pursued a
career in journalism the same career the
taliban tried killing him for pursuing
in afghanistan
last summer i was driving from
california to d.c
a quintessential cross-country road trip
as part of an american dream realized
the beauty of the great salt lake and
the wonders of yellowstone national park
were an easy reminder of the enchanting
values and ideals that symbolize america
beyond its borders
25 years ago rockets and bombs drove my
family out of our native land in
afghanistan today my youngest brother is
preparing to study engineering in
college my sister recently graduated and
started her own business my middle
brother is a physician's assistant
caring for elderly patients together
last year we bought our first home
a slice of earth we can call our own as
a family
this is what the afghan refugees who
came to the u.s in the last year are
working for now
this is what families reached for last
summer at kabul airport when they chased
after a plane
they were grasping for the hope and
freedom the world knows america will
provide
[Music]
well thank you musadique for putting it
in perspective so much that we take for
granted here you know listen there's no
question the country has issues but
always whenever you go away and you come
back i'm so i'm always so happy and so
proud to be back home in this country
and i love how he laid it all out for us
it's lovely so clear so relatable yes
carry to basketball to basketball yeah
i love what he said about his family's
success in america is america's success
yeah that is
the hope of everybody who wants to come
to this country in that video of people
clinging to the plane as it was taking
on afghanistan some people died
that's how desperately they wanted to
escape taliban rule and to come here
and for him and his family it's just a
beautiful story that is the american
dream that's what everybody wants in his
face when he said pack your bags you're
going to america a special shout out to
you stacey person yes the producer who
was behind that because those pieces are
very hard to do when it's just track
craig shea who i know from personal
experience one of the best editors we
have in the building and youtube brian
cunningham really really good those are
hard to do yeah now i just sent them
both a note that was really well done i
mean the accident of birth you know yes
how far he's come i'm glad to have him
on their new home too
that's wonderful you got it at home nice
kitchen yes all right we don't have a
good kitchen
you don't know how to use a kitchen
i didn't say i knew how to use a kitchen
tony i said i like a kitchen okay that's
true you like what comes out of it you
gather that's true i like a kitchen too